the democrats unleashed their
impeachment strategy and it's all about
emotion
president biden moves to ram through a
1.9 trillion dollar stimulus package and
the media continue playing offense
against republicans i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
ben you may have been watching over the
past few weeks as the stock market got
extremely volatile extremely quickly
and right now you may be thinking to
yourself wait aren't we about to spend
just a bunch of money we don't have
isn't that going to mean inflation down
the road
you might want to think at this point
about diversifying into precious metals
at least a little bit i know silver is
on a little bit of a run
right now well here's the good news
birch gold will allow you to diversify
into
any of the precious metals that you see
fits diversify into particularly gold
and silver we are now at the mercy of
one party control an agenda driven by
tax and spend economics
the social ramifications are going to be
a problem fiscally you can expect
compounded growth of the national debt
the systematic devaluation of the united
states dollar so what are you doing to
protect
those savings your answer should be
birch gold group birch gold group they
will help you diversify a portion of
your savings in ira or eligible 401k
into an ira backed by gold and silver
they're the premier precious metals ira
company in america
a plus better business bureau rating
countless five-star reviews thousands of
satisfied customers
there's a tidal wave of inflation it is
going to come sooner rather than later
gold is your hedge text ben to 47 47 47
for your free information kit on
precious metals ira or to speak with a
birch gold representative
today time may be running out at the
very least you want to hedge your bets
you can protect your savings right now
text ben 247 at 47 47 again and text my
name ben to 47
47 47 alrighty so we are quickly
approaching
the senate conviction trial for
president or ex-president
trump he's of course impeached in the
house with all the democrats voting in
favor of impeachment 10 republicans
voting in favor
of impeachment there was a preliminary
vote in the senate to declare
that a conviction of a person who is no
longer in office would be
unconstitutional
only five republicans voted in favor of
that those five were
senator mitt romney senator susan
collins lisa murkowski
ben sass and pat toomey were the five
who voted against the idea that this was
an
unconstitutional trial what that really
suggests is that there's not going to be
tremendous support
in favor of conviction of president
trump in the senate and here's the
reality for democrats they know this
democrats understand that the the
chances that trump is actually convicted
in the senate trial
are extremely extremely low and so what
this is all going to be about
is about ratcheting up the emotion it's
all going to be about
ratcheting up the idea that republicans
are entirely responsible
for what happened on january 6th and
they are retroactively responsible for
what happened on january 6 that they
fail
to convict trump in the senate after he
was impeached in the house
that is the idea and you saw that
strategy unleashed yesterday when dana
bash on cnn
basically said that directly to senator
rob portman who's not been an ally of
president trump's
at least on a personal level she said if
you don't convict him
aren't you basically just excusing the
behavior well that's not the way any of
this works
you can say that what trump did in the
month and months leading up to
the january 6th riots was really really
bad you can say
that he was lying to people because i
think that he was when he was claiming
that that
there was vast voter fraud that was
responsible for his failure to
win re-election when he was attacking
republican officials in arizona
and georgia and wisconsin and
pennsylvania and michigan you can say
all of that was really ugly it was not
only unpresidential it was bad morally
he never should have been doing any of
that
some of us were saying all along he had
no evidence like he had there were
courts of law he had a place where he
could have contested all of that he
tried to contest some of that
in many of those courts he didn't even
allege voter fraud okay so that was not
a worthy
endeavor at all also is that impeachable
very doubtful and when you actually look
at the impeachment charge that passed
through the house again with a
democratic bloc and then 10 republicans
voting in favor
when you look at that actual impeachment
charge the problem is that the standard
that is set by the impeachment charge
is not one that is actually warranted by
the fact because what they're actually
trying to impeach
trump for is what they call incitement
to insurrection so let me reread the
impeachment charge because remember
this is what the senate is going to have
to vote on the senate is not voting on
whether trump did something bad that
would be a censure arrangement i think
that
kevin mccarthy in the house should have
brought a censure bill and i think he
should have forced democrats to vote in
favor of that
i think that mitch mcconnell should put
forward a censure okay but
as far as impeachment there you actually
have to fulfill the charge that you are
making
and here's what the actual impeachment
charge is just to refresh everybody's
memory because again this is a legal
proceeding
this is not just a let's vote on whether
we think trump is bad after he's out of
office routine
so here's what they are accusing him of
they say that in his contact while
president of the united states and in
violation of his constitutional oath
faithfully to execute the office of
president of the united states and to
the best of his ability
preserve protect and defend the
constitution and in violation of his
constitutional duty to take care that
the laws be faithfully executed
trump engaged in high crimes and
misdemeanors by inciting violence
against the government of the united
states
in that on january 6 pursuant to the
12th amendment to the constitution of
the united states the vice president of
the united states house of
representatives
and senate met at the u.s capitol for a
joint session of congress to count the
votes of the electoral college
in the months preceding the joint
session president trump repeatedly
issued false statements
asserting that the presidential election
results were the product of widespread
fraud
and should not be accepted by the
american people or certified by state or
federal officials
and now if they'd wanted to impeach him
solely on that basis theoretically they
could have tried they could have said
that that was an abusive power that he
shouldn't be challenging election
results would have been awkward for them
since for four years they had been
claiming that trump was not legitimately
elected because of russian interference
and they keep claiming
that governor stacy abrams is actually
the governor
stacey abrams as opposed to just stacey
abrams failed gubernatorial candidate in
georgia
shortly before the joint session
commenced trump addressed a crowd at the
ellipse in washington dc
there he reiterated false claims that we
won this election and we won it by a
landslide he also willfully made
statements that in context encouraged
and foreseeably resulted in
lawless action at the capitol such as if
you don't fight like hell you're not
going to have a country anymore
thus incited by president trump members
of the crowd he had addressed in an
attempt to among other
objectives interfere with the joint
sessions solemn constitutional duty to
certify the results of the 2020
presidential election
unlawfully breached and vandalized the
capital injured and killed law
enforcement personnel
menace members of congress the vp and
congressional personnel and engaged in
other violent deadly destructive and
seditious acts right so that is the
basic contention is that trump ramped
everybody up and then on january 6th
he unleashed the mob on the capitol
building and that is the narrative that
has been pushed throughout
now there are a couple of countervailing
points to be made here
one is that he actively said in that
speech that people should go peacefully
protest over at the capitol building
that does matter i know people are
dismissing that it does matter
okay because the truth is that congress
members
presidents lots of people in politics
use inflammatory language all the time
that can be a not wonderful thing and
also not incitement to violence
and when republicans point this out
democrats wave their hands and say it's
not comparable but
in many cases it absolutely is
comparable bernie sanders suggested that
the republican healthcare plan was for
you to die
he said that and then one of his
supporters went and shot up a
congressional baseball game does that
make him guilty of incitement no
barack obama kept saying over and over
during his presidency that policing in
america
was systemically racist and kept making
statements
about the inherent racism of the
american system racism was baked into
the american dna then a black lives
matter supporter went and shot six cops
in dallas was was obama responsible for
that no he was not
that was not incitement to violence it
can be irresponsible language without
being incitement of violence
and the question of causation comes into
play here
so on a legal level there are two levels
of causation that usually come into play
when it comes to law
one is what we call but four causation
and the other is what we call proximate
cause
but for causation is a very low standard
but for causation is the idea that but
for your activity x would not have
happened
the problem is that that applies to a
wide variety of activities that are not
in and of themselves guilty
right but four causation would suggest
that
for example if i were if i were
hit by if if if i were hit by a train
right and that morning i had missed the
bus and therefore i had to take the
train
the butt floor causation would suggest
that because i missed
the because i missed the bus i was
therefore hit by the train
does that mean that the bus driver is
responsible for me being hit by the
train no
it absolutely does not and but four
causation is a very weak standard is not
usually used in law
then there's proximate cause proximate
causes something different that suggests
that your action was not only necessary
to the chain of events but it was causal
of the chain of events that was
foreseeable that you saying this stuff
would have resulted in the overrunning
of the capital building
the problem with that is that nobody
really oversaw the overrunning of the
capitol building
except maybe for the fbi who didn't do
their damn job and it turns out that
they had indicators according to the new
york times that there were groups that
were mobilizing in advance of trump's
january 6th speech
in order to go and do these things so
unless you can show that trump knew that
those people were going to go do that
and was encouraging those people to go
do that
it's gonna be very difficult to show
proximate cause in this particular case
deep political irresponsibility does not
equate to incitement
there's not a lawyer in america who
really believes that trump is guilty of
legal incitement here
so what they're really saying is that
trump did a bunch of stuff that's bad
and because it's bad he shouldn't be
allowed to hold office again and so
we're going to convict him in the senate
okay well the question is when does bad
rise to the level
of convictable in the senate and what
standard are you setting for when
something is convictable in the senate
so in other words let's say the riots
had not occurred would trump have been
impeached let's say trump had made that
rally
and nobody has stormed the capitol
building right what is activity in and
of itself
have been impeachable on that basis i
think most people would say
probably not it would have been bad
would have been ugly but it's the riots
that made it quote-unquote impeachable
well the problem is if you didn't cause
the riots
then it's not really impeachable either
right so that is the question that
should be up for debate
at the actual at the actual senate trial
right is the question of actual
causation
what did trump know when did he know it
who knew what
what was the activity on that day like
right that should really be the case but
because democrats know that they are
going to be hard-pressed to actually
make that case in the public view
because they know that there's gonna be
pushback from republicans along a wide
variety of lines including
you know you guys used a lot of
inflammatory rhetoric during the summer
when two billion dollars in property
damage was done
and i believe about 20 people were
killed over the course of the summer in
various antifa and blm riots
you know where were you guys is that
incitement i think democrats want to
avoid all that so what they're doing
instead is they're ramping up the talk
of what actually happened that day
they're going to turn the senate trial
into essentially a cavalcade of
recollections of the horror of that day
i have nothing against that i think it's
perfectly fine i think we should all be
aware of how horrible that day was
i think that frankly republicans who
were threatened should be calling
witnesses to talk about how horrible
that day was i think we should all agree
how horrible
that day was how threatening that day
was i mean i talked to active republican
members of congress while the riots were
going on while they were
being sheltered in place i talked to at
least a couple of senators i believe
that day and at least one congress
person
all of whom were being sheltered in
place and
it was really really bad and i think
that the american people should be
forced to look at that i think that's
good that the american people remember
that that is not a case for incitement
it is not a case for impeachment we'll
get to
what the actual agenda here is in just
one second
first let us talk about the fact that
you don't trust big tech companies these
days nor should you the big tech
companies have been making it very clear
that they wish to target people of
certain political viewpoints democrats
are urging them to do so the media are
urging them to do so
so why exactly are you allowing them to
monetize your data
right they're they're already planning
on how they're going to quash stuff that
you like
meanwhile they're using your data to
monetize themselves why not just protect
your data protect that data from big
tech with the vpn i trust for my own
online protection express vpn
when i use expressvpn my connection gets
rerouted through their secure encrypted
servers so the companies can't see my ip
address at all my internet activity
becomes anonymized my network data is
encrypted
i recommend expressvpn to anyone who
uses the internet so you know
everyone the best part is you don't need
to be tech savvy at all to use
expressvpn you just download the app on
your phone or computer you tap one
button
now you're protected protect your
internet activity with the vpn i use
every day visit expressvpn.com to get
three extra months free
on a one year package that's expes
e-x-p-r-e-s-vpn.com
to get three extra months for free
expressvpn.com
slash ben once more that's
expressvpn.com get three extra months
free
on that one-year package okay so the
democratic strategy here
during this trial is not going to be to
make the legal case for why trump
was responsible for what happened at the
capitol again
that should be the case they are making
instead
of making the causation case what
they're going to do is they're going to
recount the horrors of that day
and then they're going to use how
horrific that day was in order to
essentially smear every republican
and the idea is going to be that if you
voted for trump in 2016 it was
foreseeable and if you voted for 2020
trump in 2020 it was foreseeable if you
think that trump's
behavior is egregious and doesn't meet
the impeachable standard
then you are responsible for all of this
right that is the goal is to broaden out
the indictment of january 6th to include
not just people who engage in criminal
activity but people who engaged in
non-criminal activity and not just to
indict people who engaged in cynical
politicking
but to in insight but to to somehow
indict people who are not engaged in any
of that
right the the concentric circles of
blame are going to be widened and
widened and widened and at the very
center
is january 6th so what you're going to
see over the next several weeks is
democrats coming out and telling their
stories of horror of january 6th and
then members of the media urging them to
impute that horror to everybody who
disagrees with them
on the other side of the aisle you're
seeing this over and over and over so
for example mondaire jones
he's a democrat congress person from new
york and he and he and many other
democrats have been claiming
that in the midst of the capital rights
they were literally fearful of sharing
space with republicans
they were fearful of being in the same
offices as republicans during the riots
because they felt like the republicans
were actually on the side of the rioters
now
those writers were there presumably to
take prisoner or people like mike pence
mike pence is donald trump's vice
president they weren't going to be kind
to mitch mcconnell
or any of the other senators presumably
okay they were not there to make friends
with congress people on either side of
the aisle
i was talking to congress people who
were in the rooms with democrats while
all of this was happening
okay but monday jones he goes out there
and he claims that he was fearful of
sharing space with republicans because
he thought that the republicans
were essentially part of the effort to
go ahead and kill
members of congress now this is a claim
that has been made over and over and
over by democrats
i've yet to see a shred of evidence to
support it if they have evidence that
there are members of congress who are
actively coordinating with the rioters
in order to do harm to congress people
those congress people then cr they
committed actual treason
like actual treason legal treason right
if they were complicit in a scheme to
overthrow the workings of the united
states government
by selling out the location of their
colleagues in coordination with
criminals
intent on doing harm they're accessories
to attempted murder
right so i would like to see some
evidence of those sorts of allegations
instead of just these broad
ranging allegations without any evidence
to support them so far as i can tell
like seriously let us know because i
don't want traders in congress do you
yeah but here was monday jones making
the case that he was fearful of sharing
space with republicans for example
you cannot trust a number of these
people and that is
that is an extraordinary thing to say
about uh
you know about your colleagues in the
united states congress but the fact is
that a number of these people in
addition to having incited that violent
insurrection that we saw
uh likely were coordinating
uh more more explicitly with with these
people and so
and the investigation is ongoing and
every day we learn more about
um the level of um the level of
involvement of a number of our
colleagues
okay he's saying a lot of stuff right
there if we learn about that
that would be criminal activity and
those people should go to jail at a
minimum
i mean it seems to me that if you commit
active treason against the american
government and you're an elected
congress person
that i mean that may fulfill the the the
actual legal
requirements of treason that ends with
the death penalty under the constitution
of the united states
so i mean let's see some evidence of
that sort of thing but again
that's not the goal here the goal here
is to indict everybody who disagrees
with you and to use the most colorful
language possible
in doing that the person who's been
doing that the most over the course of
the last couple of days has of course
been alexander ocasio-cortez who last
night took to instagram for 90 minutes
to talk about her experiences at the
capitol
now there are some people on the right
who have been mocking her retelling of
her story at the capitol i'm not mocking
her retelling of the story at the
capitol i know that there are people who
are in legit danger
i don't think that she's wrong to have
feared for her life in the middle of
what was going on
in the capital riots as we'll see
however i think that she is wrong
when she then starts to suggest that
fellow members of congress
are akin to rapists this is where i
think she goes wrong
so we'll get to aoc in just one moment
because she has been the most a colorful
exponent
of this sort of a line of argumentation
which is something truly horrible
happened
i was traumatized by it therefore
something unrelated
we'll get to this in just one second
first let us talk about the fact there's
a lot happening in your front door these
days you're having packages delivered
and groceries delivered
now for for us we've had a lot of
friends and family stopping by just to
say
happy birthday to my daughter a lot
happening at that front porch you want
to make sure you know what's going on on
your property at all times
this is why you need the ring of video
doorbell with ring you can see and speak
to whoever is at your front door from
anywhere right on the phone
you're not going to miss a visitor
whether it's your neighbor your dinner
or your groceries you can keep those
packages and delivery safe
with motion detection you'll get
notified even if they don't ring the
doorbell if someone stops by
something's going on ring will let you
know i love having that ring video
doorbell i've actually added ring
security cameras
around our house as well i've got like a
floodlight cam for the driveway i've got
spotlight cams and different places in
the house
i gotta keep track of my three kids
seven and four
and a little baby who is now moving
around because i only have two eyes and
they don't move in opposite directions
so i need to be able to keep an eye on
all of them at once
the cameras help me do just that protect
your whole home with
ring alarm it's a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install yourself right now get a
special offer on the ring welcome kit at
ringgit.com it comes with rings of video
doorbell 3 and chime pro it's the
perfect way to upgrade your front door
and start your ring experience head on
over to ring.com that is ring.com
ben okay so yesterday aoc went on her
instagram sorry the honorable
representative alexander ocasio-cortez
d-twitch she went on her instagram which
is the place to make
very serious allegations instagram and
she
talked about her experiences during the
day there are a couple controversial
things that she said in here
let me start with what is
uncontroversial it is it has got to be a
horrifying experience if you're a member
of congress you are rushed
out of your office to an alternative
site because rioters have stormed the
capitol
so i'm not going to doubt that she was
freaked out
and the the one part of this story
that's a little bit humorous is that she
apparently she landed
in the office of representative katie
porter and and she said that katie
porter was sitting there sipping coffee
uh and basically waiting for all of it
to end so kudos to
katie porter in any case uh aoc
describes
those experiences but then she goes on
to to do a couple of things that are
pretty unpleasant one is that she
suggests that when a capitol police
officer arrived in her office to warn
her to go to someplace else now the
writers never actually got into her
office
to be clear a capital police officer
arrived in her office and told her that
she needed to rush out of her office and
get to someplace safer
when the capitol police officer arrived
she suggested that she had doubts
whether he was actually a capital police
officer
because he was flustered and because he
was white
and that was something that she said
which i mean again
i don't think now is the time to
actually be like crapping all over the
capitol police who are
doing their jobs and protecting members
of congress but i guess that um
it is not foreign to democrats
unfortunately to crap all over the
police
at every available opportunity in any
case uh aoc
talks about that but the parts again
that are legit when she talks about
being scared and traumatized
i've been in the middle of uh difficult
situations not to this extent obviously
but i've been in the center of
situations where i'm speaking and we
require 600 police officers in order to
guard my speech at berkeley
or i've been in the middle of a quasi
riot like a small scale riot
over at to cal state los angeles where
we required police officers people were
banging on the doors
it's not pleasant it's not pla and this
must have been way more unpleasant than
that right i mean this must have been
truly scary obviously i mean there were
people there
who were banging for blood and injuring
police officers so i mean this was way
worse than anything i've ever had to
experience so i don't doubt
that her trauma and experiences are real
here where she goes next that's where i
have some problems so here's what
alexander ocasio-cortez had to say on
her
on her stream last night these folks who
tell us
to move on that it's not a big deal that
we should forget what's happened
or even telling us to apologize
um these are the same tactics of abusers
and um
[Music]
i'm a survivor of sexual assault
um and i haven't told many people that
in my life
um but
when we go through trauma
trauma compounds on each other
okay so a couple of things one sexual
assault is something that ought to be
treated
with the utmost utmost seriousness the
utmost care
when people talk about sexual assault it
should not be done cavalierly
sexual assault i'm not suggesting that
she's talking about her own sexual
assault cavalierly there i don't think
she is
okay sexual assault is in my opinion the
worst crime a human being can commit
against another human being i've long
suggested that rape should be punishable
by death
i think it is a worse crime in many
cases than murder rape is just
a horrific horrific thing obviously so
two things can be true
at once as always one sexual assault is
a grave grave matter a supremely grave
matter
the gravest crime one person can commit
on another person
second to compare sexual assault
to people you disagree with politically
saying
that impeachment is unnecessary at this
point for a person
who did not actually participate in the
capital riots trump
that is an injustice it's an injustice
okay the the the suggestion that what
the people she was talking about there
were uh were ted cruz
and josh hawley the senators who have
both suggested that
we should move on in terms of
impeachment right not that we should
forget what happened on january 6th
not that the criminals of january 6
shouldn't be punished but that
impeaching trump at this point he's
already out of office so there's
constitutional questions there
or linking him directly via modes of
incitement
to the activity at the capitol building
that the evidence isn't there for that
to compare those people
to rapists which is what she's doing
right there
that's that's an ugly thing to do it's a
really really ugly thing to do
and you you're not granted unlimited
license to compare people
to your sexual assault or because you
have suffered a sexual assault
okay that the the person who is
comparable to the sexual assault or is
the sexual assaulter who should be in
prison who should be in jail i hope to
god that she goes to the police and
whoever sexually assaulted her
ends up in prison because that's where
they belong at a minimum
but the the attempt to suggest that josh
howley and ted cruz are like abusers who
want you to forget about
the abuse to compare them to people who
have engaged in sexual assault
it's truly extraordinary and this is
coming from the same congresswoman who
in the past week
has suggested that ted cruz tried to
have her murdered without
evidence which is again normally when
you allege that somebody is an accessory
to murder you ought to have some
evidence to that effect otherwise this
makes you a false witness
they're biblical commandments against
such things so what is the actual goal
here the actual goal here
is to align anyone who you disagree with
politically
or disagrees with you on impeachment as
not only complicit in that but complicit
in the worst crimes available to
humankind
and that's really inappropriate stuff
come from from a
sitting congress person that again that
is not to undercut anything that she
says about the trauma she experienced
during the day
that is not to undercut anything that
she has said about the trauma of her
experience as a sexual assault survivor
it is to suggest that you don't get to
compare people to sexual assaulters
without evidence that they have
committed sexual assault the worst crime
you can commit against another human
being
and you certainly don't get to do it on
the basis that they disagree with you
about impeachment of a person who's
already out of office and who
in my opinion didn't commit an
impeachable offense anyway in using
inflammatory inappropriate and ugly
language
if the new standard is that if you use
inflammatory ugly language
in order to quote unquote incite and
uprising and alexander ocasio-cortez has
some explaining to do here is
aoc justifying black lives matter
violence during the summer here
i mean again i don't think that she
should be impeached from congress for
this
here is alexander ocasio-cortez doing
this again during the summer a little
bit of a flashback here
if you're trying to call for the end of
unrest but you don't believe health care
is a human right
if you're afraid to say black lives
matter
if you don't if you're too scared
to call out police brutality then you
aren't asking for an
end of unrest you are asking for
injustice to continue
and for your people to continue to
endure the violence of poverty
the violence of a lack of housing access
the violence of police brutality
and not say a damn thing that's what
you're asking for
okay so again there she was using logic
during the summer basically suggesting
that if you're not calling for universal
health care
then you ought to just be okay with the
riots that were happening during the
summer i mean
that's as inflammatory as anything that
trump said in the lead up to january 6th
so if the goal here in an impeachment
trial is to demonstrate causality
if the goal on an impeachment trial is
to demonstrate actual incitement you're
going to have to do better
than than what trump did on january 6
and so that's why
my deep suspicion here is that for
democrats this is all a pr mover i mean
joe biden has basically said that joe
biden has said
that he understands that there's not
going to be a conviction here that
essentially this is all about just
brow beating republicans who didn't have
anything to do with january 6th
and many of whom were in the same exact
rooms as democrats waiting to be preyed
upon
and and lumping all of those people in
and and you wonder
why republicans are again suspicious of
impeachment it's because of exactly
this type of move right this
is all part of a broader effort by
members of the democratic party and
members of the media to lump republicans
in with their most extreme
outliers right to take the most extreme
components of the
of the republican voting base and then
say that is all of you people that is
everyone
now here's the thing it was mitch
mcconnell who got up on the floor of the
senate after the capital riots
and suggested that american government
had withstood the predations
of these radicals it was vice president
mike pence who presided over the actual
certification of the vote that made him
not vice president anymore there's
republicans who did that
so the next move for the media are of
course is of course to to suggest that
everybody on the right
is now in league with marjorie taylor
green she's become the new outlier that
we can smear everybody with
you just take margaret retailer green
and paint the entire republican party
with the specter
of marjorie taylor great now again
here's the problem most of the
republican leadership as far as i can
tell has condemned martial taylor
green's
comments in the past about jewish space
lasers and
and the parkland massacre and all this
nuttiness she's a crazy person
and a radical and she believes crazy
radical things okay here is what mitch
mcconnell had to say about that
yesterday quote
he's talking about liz cheney right liz
chaney has been targeted by some
republicans she's the number three in
the house gop caucus and she voted in
favor
of impeaching trump again i think that
there's a case to be made
to vote in favor i think there's a case
we made against i'm on the against side
but i don't think that if you vote in
favor
that it's unthinkable in any way in any
case liz cheney
right has been hit with a wave of of
rage by some members of the republican
base
here's what mitch mcconnell said he said
liz cheney is a leader with deep
convictions and the courage to act on
them she's an important leader in our
party in our nation
i'm grateful for her service i look
forward to continuing to work with her
on the crucial issues facing
our nation and then he went on and just
blasted the living crap out of marjory
taylor green
right he said that she embraces looney
lies and conspiracy theory she said that
that's a cancer for the republican party
he said in a statement quote somebody
who suggested that perhaps no airplane
hit the pentagon on 9 11
that horrifying school shootings were
pre-staged that the clintons crashed jfk
junior's airplane
is not living in reality this has
nothing to do with the challenges facing
american families or the robust debates
on substance that can strengthen
our party okay but the goal of the left
is of course not to let republicans
disassociate from marjorie taylor green
the goal is to lump them all in with
marjorie taylor green now i will note
that the democrats are very keen on
expelling marjorie taylor greene
from congress this is their goal right
now now cynthia mckinney as far as i'm
aware is not expelled from congress
and cynthia mckinney i believe lost an
election okay but
in any case ilhan omar is treated as a
member of leadership
in the democratic party rashida talib
who's an anti-semite
is treated as a membership a leadership
member in the
in the democratic party i'm right about
mckinney by the way she was defeated and
primary by hank johnson who is similarly
radical but not quite as
outspokenly crazy in any case the
democrats are saying that
taylor greene should be expelled from
congress well no you have to do
something as an actual member of
congress in order to be expelled from
congress
she hasn't done anything ex expulsion
worthy yet this is why we actually have
elections
and she will be primaried and my unders
my hope my great hope is that she will
lose in the same way that steve king
lost his primary inside the republican
party here was debbie wasserman schultz
who absolutely did not
work to expel any of the radical
democrats in her caucus saying that
margery taylor green should be expelled
if she had honor of course she would
resign if she possessed shame
censure in an apology might suffice
expulsion
is a fitting punishment but it takes a
two-thirds vote of the house and that
would require support from enough
republicans
who aren't morally bankrupt which is
unlikely
so reducing the future harm that she can
cause in congress
and denying her a seat at committee
tables where fact-based policies will be
crafted
is both a suitable punishment and a
proper restraint of her influence
okay so again the the push by debbie
wasserman schultz
who is the former head of the dnc uh to
expel margery taylor green what that
really is about is then saying that if
you don't vote to expel marjory taylor
green right it's the it's the
it's the sort of analog to what's
happening with impeachment if you don't
vote to expel margaret taylor green
again there may not be a legal basis for
expelling margery taylor green then who
is a job and should not be in congress
then this means that you are complicit
with marjorie taylor green and this is
the pitch that is being made by
democrats in the media particularly
michelle goldberg
who again is a a fool and uh and a
simpleton but rights for the new york
times she has a piece titled it's
marjorie taylor green's party now
she embarrasses some republicans but
she's no outlier no she's pretty much an
outlier
i mean she believes that jewish space
lasers are responsible for a wildfire in
california
and while that would be kind of awesome
as a person who would undoubtedly be
part of the
the council meeting on friday nights to
decide where exactly to deploy the
jewish
space laser um i will say that i don't
think
that that is a mainstream position
inside the republican party i will tell
you what is a mainstream position inside
the democratic party is that jews are
privileged
jews are privileged white people that is
a mainstream position inside the
democratic party these days which seems
a lot more threatening to jews
than the fringe view that we control a
space laser
which again there's an old joke in
jewish circles
in which there's a uh there's two jewish
guys and they're sitting on a park bench
and one of them
is reading disturber which is the nazi
newspaper and he's reading their sturmer
and he's laughing in 1935
and the other true tournament is what
are you laughing at he says
i'm reading all these headlines and it
says that we control the world and it
says we control the banking system and
it says that we control
the army and it says that we control
finance i mean
like i read this stuff and it's great
news
and the wonderful thing about uh about
being a jew is that everybody always
imputes you
world-breaking powers that if jews had
had
our history would be not quite so bleak
but in any case
the the argument being made by folks on
the left of course
is that margaret taylor green is the
republican party just like they said
steve king was the republican party and
todd igan was the republican party
and christine o'donnell is the
republican party and donald trump was
the republican
they're all the republican party whoever
is the most outlandish outlier that is
the person who is the republican party
so says so says michelle goldberg she
says steve king the former republican
congressman from iowa must feel robbed
two years ago he was stripped of all his
committee assignments after asking
in an interview with the new york times
white nationalist white supremacist
western civilization how did that
language become offensive
the republican party threw its weight
behind king's primary challenger and he
was whisked off the national stage
since then standards have changed okay
let me just make something clear
when republicans like me led the charge
for primary steve king
we were given zero credit by the
democratic press none
okay the democratic press instead
suggested that we actually secretly
backed steve king
i'm not kidding this is a thing that
happened people were like oh well you
know why
sure they they took away all his
committee assignments and they had him
primaried
but really they're all like steve king
aren't they so now the new steve king is
on marjory taylor green
they say representative marjorie taylor
green this is uh michelle goldberg in
the new york times
is every bit as bigoted as king and ten
times is unhinged by now you surely
heard her theory that california
wildfires
may have been caused by space lasers
controlled by jewish bankers
this wasn't green's first foray into
anti-semitism in 2018
she shared a notorious white nationalist
video in which a holocaust denier
claimed that zionist supremacists have
schemed to promote immigration and
miscegenation
recently green met with the far-right
british commentator katie hopkins who
has described migrants
as roaches etc etc
they say kevin mccarthy the republican
house leader this michelle goldberg is
meeting with green
it's far from clear he'll act against
her because she represents much of the
party's base
oh um is that right is that correct
when the new yorkers charles bethea met
a group of green's local supporters last
year they were generally familiar with q
anon
several agree that democrats are
controlled by satan
um well again i would assume that people
who support her support a lot of what
she does but that doesn't mean that
everybody who supports her does or that
a
obscure first term congress person from
a contested primary in georgia is
representative of the entire democratic
party but
doesn't matter the whole goal here is to
suggest that american conservatism
is part and parcel of this insanity
michelle goldberg says
american conservatism particularly its
evangelical strain now the christians
bad bad christians has fostered
derangement in its ranks for decades
insisting that no source of information
outside its own self-reinforcing
ideological bubble is trustworthy
oh the irony of a columnist for the new
york times suggesting that siloing on
information
and creating a bubble of your own making
is a problem
oh the irony if you're steeped in
creationism says
michelle goldberg and believe that
elites are lying to you about the
origins of life on earth it's not a
stretch to believe they are lying to you
about a life-threatening virus
okay so first of all a lot of church
believers even a lot of new earth
creationists
a lot of them are going to take the
vaccine there are a lot of they're a
bunch of lefties we're not going to take
the vaccine so
that's a bit of a stretch if you know
the history of the revisionist
is the revisionist version of the
christian right in which god deeded
america to the faithful
plural pluralism will feel like the
theft of your birthright
if you believe the last democratic
president was illegitimate as trump and
other brothers claimed it's not hard to
believe dark forces would foist another
unconstitutional leader
on the country there was a moment after
the capital riot when it seemed as if a
critical mass of the republican party
was recoiling at what it had created
but the moment passed the moment passed
on monday politico reported if
republicans don't strip green of
committee assignments democrats will try
to do it bringing the issue to the house
floor
republican members will have the chance
to distance themselves from her if they
don't
it will be because they know she belongs
yes i'm sure that that is what you guys
would love
there's a reason that she is now the
most well-known name in republican
circles and it ain't because of
republicans it's because of democrats
this column is mirrored by one from
eugene robinson in today's washington
post
titled literally if the gop is to rise
from the ashes it has to burn first oh
look inflammatory language literally
inflammatory
language it has to burn first before a
sane responsible political party can
rise like a phoenix from the ashes of
today's dangerously unhinged gop
there must be ashes to rise from the
nation is going to have to destroy the
republican party
to save it you might think the violent
and deadly january 6th insurrection at
the capitol
would snap the gop back into reality
unbelievably though you would be wrong
if anything the party is headed deeper
into the wilderness
look at how the two most powerful
republicans left in washington behaved
last week
kevin mccarthy made a pilgrimage to
mar-a-lago to bend the knee to trump and
mitch mcconnell voted to question
whether trump's coming impeachment trial
is even constitutional the gop now bears
no resemblance to the party of abraham
lincoln says eugene robinson
okay my favorite part of this is where
michelle goldberg and eugene robinson
pretend
that three minutes ago the republican
party was saying and they were cool with
it
ten years ago they were saying the
republican party was unhinged nothing
has changed they just found a new brick
to hit republicans with
eugene robinson says this is now the
party of marjorie taylor green yeah yeah
yeah again is kevin mccarthy posing on
the cover of magazines with marjorie
taylor green
a lot more case that the democratic
party is the party of ilhan omar recited
to liberty aoc
than the case that the republican party
is the party of marjorie taylor greene
eugene robinson admits that mccarthy and
mcconnell don't believe this nonsense
but they do believe they are within
striking range regaining control of both
the house
and the senate and they are choosing
power over principle
their their hopes must be utterly dashed
so yeah this is this is the actual goal
right in the end
is that and again there's another column
in the washington post by colbert king
saying the same thing
the gop once knew what to do about
problems like margaery taylor
green but now again i'm not going to
listen to this crap
from people who literally put ilhan omar
and anti-semite and rashida talib on the
cover of magazines
like that it just does not wash it seems
extraordinarily cynical because it is
extraordinarily cynical and it is all
part and parcel of a broader attempt
that has been going since january 6th to
suggest that every republican every
conservative is responsible for what
happened
on january 6th and the more you say it
the more it will be true it doesn't make
it true because it's not true
it hasn't been true it is not true even
the people who believe that the election
was stolen
are not responsible for the people who
went into the capital p
lots of people in the united states can
believe lots of horrible and terrible
and untrue
lying things but lots of people do that
doesn't in the same way that black lives
matters
supporters believe that america's
systemically racist which i think is a
lie that is unbased on facts
hey even though they believe that
they're not responsible for people going
in burning cities
okay in the same way even people who
believe the untruth that the election
was stolen
if they weren't rioting at the capitol
and storming the capitol building you
can't blame even the people who went and
peacefully protested with trump and then
left
when they saw what was going on for the
people who stormed the capital okay but
this is exact but
of course the same standard just does
not apply for the democratic party it
just does not
okay in just one second we are going to
get to the breakdown of political
bipartisanship so we've seen in terms of
policy we've already seen
the breakdown of supposed bipartisanship
uh in in terms of
the moment of unity that did not last
for beyond five minutes during january
6th
now we'll move on to actual policy
because joe biden is a united not a
divider except when it comes to you know
all the things
we'll get to that in a moment first when
the founders wrote the constitution the
first thing they did
was make sacred the rights of the
individual to share their ideas without
limitation by their government
the second thing they did was secure the
rights of individuals to protect that
speech and their lives with force
if needed owning a rifle it's a big
responsibility building rifles is no
different
bravo company manufacturing builds a
professional-grade product it is built
to combat standards that's because bcm
believes the same level of protection
should be provided to every american
regardless if they are a private citizen
or a professional
the people at bcm assume when a rifle
leaves their shop it will be used in a
life or death situation by a responsible
citizen
law enforcement officer or a soldier
overseas they make excellent tools i'm
deeply concerned always about my
personal safety and the safety of my
family
there's a reason i own a bcm rifle it is
a fantastic
fantastic tool for protecting myself to
learn more about bravo company
manufacturing head on over to
bravocompanymfg.com
you can discover more about their
products special offers and upcoming
news that is bravocompanymfg.com if you
need more convincing
find out even more about bcm and the
awesome people who make their products
at youtube.com
bravo company usa again that's
youtube.com bravo
company usa okay in just one second we
are going to get to democrats
setting the clock back to zero days
since bipartisanship okay they're
sending that clock
back to uh days since we uh abandoned
bipartisanship sending that clock back
to zero
first daily where is getting involved in
the culture starting with entertainment
content as you know we released our
first movie run hide fight exclusively
for daily wire members you can now catch
it over at dailywire.com on our mobile
app on our streaming apps
at apple tv and roku if you're not a
daily ware member yet use promo code rhf
that's run hide fight for 25
off again that's promo code rhf to get
off there's a reason audiences are
loving it it is well above ninety
percent
on rotten tomatoes among audiences
critics not so much that's the kind of
stuff that you're gonna get at daily
wire the stuff
that woke critics are not a fan of but
you're gonna love catch it at
dailywire.com on our mobile app on our
streaming apps at apple tv and roku if
you're not a daily ware member yet
use promo code rhf to get 25 off that is
run hide fight rhf for 25
off you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
meanwhile in policy terms remember that
time that joe biden said he was gonna be
a moderate
yeah that was funny that's fine some of
us warned you that was not going to
happen
some of us suggested to the so-called
never trump republicans that you guys
who keep saying
joe biden is going to be a moderate
uniter uh nope no he's not
he's simply a facade for the radical
left and what has happened he is a
facade for the radical left all his
administration has done so far
is issue more executive orders in the
first week of any term than any
president in american history
and those executive orders are filled
with things like boys should race
in girls sports and also we should make
sure that racial equity is the basis of
all of our policies meaning racial
favoritism
based on supposed victimized status by
group so yeah things are going great
also they're gonna ram through a one
point trill 1.9 trillion dollar
coveted package that is unnecessary it
is not necessary
what we need right now is temporary help
for people who are in need
we don't need more aid that is just
thrown out the window to people who have
jobs who are currently working we also
don't need people to be paid more than
they were making when they were actually
working
that is not something that we require
right now and yet that is exactly what
is being proposed
by joe biden he's also proposing a raise
to 15 minimum wage which makes no sense
federally
because it turns out the states have
widely variant styles of living
15 goes a long way in mississippi it
doesn't go halfway in new york
the idea of a federal minimum wage is
idiocy on its face especially when it's
raised to some
exorbitant level that is greater than
like one-third of all the wage earners
in a particular state
in any case democrats they could have
come up with a with a compromised deal
here
in fact 10 republicans headed on over to
the white house to talk with joe biden
democrats headed on over uh democrats
were meeting with republicans it was all
supposed to be
happy bipartisanship susan collins led
the way the senator for maine and she
was super happy to talk with joe biden
it was a very good exchange of views
i wouldn't say that we came together
on a package tonight no one expected
that
in a two-hour meeting but what we did
agreed to do
is to follow up and talk further i think
it was
an excellent meeting and we're very
appreciative
that it's his first official meeting in
the oval office
the president chose to spend so much
time with us
oh well i mean i'm glad that susan
collins is feeling super flattered by
spending time with joe biden i mean like
that's
the best it's the way they spend time
and they play like d and d and it's
it's just fantastic right they sit there
they play board games they have a cup of
tea
meanwhile nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
are just gonna ram through this bill
they're just gonna ram it through
according to the daily wire senate
majority leader chuck schumer and house
speaker nancy pelosi introduced a joint
resolution on monday afternoon that will
allow them to pass president joe biden's
coronavirus stimulus package without
needing support from the republican
party
introduction of a joint budget
resolution is the first step to
potentially enacting a budget
reconciliation
bill one legislative tool available to
congress to quickly pass bipartisan
covet relief legislation
said a joint statement from the two
democratic leaders the resolution
outlines the reconciliation instructions
for each house and senate committee
or how much funding can be spent in
their jurisdictions
congress has the responsibility to
quickly deliver immediate comprehensive
relief to the american people hurting
from covet 19 the cost of an action is
high and growing the time for decisive
action
is now remember it was democrats who are
holding this thing up while trump was
president
and they were holding it up before the
election for months even though there
was a bipartisan deal in place
they rejected a big bipartisan deal in
order to literally hold it up until
after the election nancy pelosi admitted
that but now is the time to make sure
this gets done
and we're just going to ram this thing
through so while susan collins is doing
happy talk
with joe biden jen sackey the white
house press secretary is like
yeah i'm glad they came over and yeah we
had some fun and
it was pretty great we played rummy cube
but also we're not going to do anything
they want we're just going to do exactly
what we want to do
this is an exchange an opportunity to
exchange ideas
to have a conversation uh that's why he
invited them over here
to the white house there are some real
impacts which he will certainly
reiterate
um as he has publicly and privately in
many conversations but
they've put forward some ideas he's
happy to hear from them but he's uh
also feels uh strongly about the need to
make sure the size of the package meets
this moment and
and feels the american people expect
that of their elected officials so in
other words i'm glad they showed up
good to see them also we're just going
to completely ignore everything that
they just had to say
super bipartisanship happening right
there it's like the simpsons
set that clock back to zero days since
we broke bipartisanship
right set that clock back to zero it was
it was that like not even a day
and setting it back to zero right now
the white house put a statement also
they said that the president and vice
president had a substantive and
productive discussion with republican
senators this evening at the white house
the group shared a desire to get help to
the american people who are suffering
through the worst health and economic
crisis in a generation
while there were areas of agreement the
president also reiterated his view that
congress must respond boldly and
urgently
whenever congress is bold and urgent
hold on your wallet man whenever a
politician says bold and urgent what
they mean is we are going to spend more
money than has ever been created by god
or man
they noted many areas in which the
republican senator's proposal does not
address the problems biden reiterated
while he is hopeful that the rescue plan
can pass with bipartisan support a
reconciliation package is a path
to achieve that end the president also
made clear that the american rescue plan
was carefully designed to meet the
stakes of the moment
any changes in it cannot leave the
nation short of its pressing needs so in
other words
so thanks so much for stopping by it's
been fun also we're gonna completely
ignore everything
you have to say captain unity unitying
it up over there
i mean like super lots of unity
happening inside the democratic party so
here's what we've gotten in the age of
unity the new golden era so far
we have gotten if you don't vote to
convict trump in the impeachment trial
this means that you are in league with
the january 6th rioters
that if you believe that margery taylor
green is a nut job and a crazy person
but also you can't expel her from
congress for stuff that she said before
the election
that that's why we have an actual an
election process in the united states
that if you actually believe that you
can remove it from committees and stuff
that makes you the party of
marjorie taylor green and also if you
want to cut a deal on stimulus
if you want to cut a deal on coveted
relief like right now and you've wanted
to for months but it's not joe biden's
deal we're just going to ignore you so
super unity happening right now loving
the unity feeling the unity
there's no unity meanwhile speaking of
no unity
it's always fun to see how the how the
democratic party manipulates the media
and how the media just go along with it
it really is fun
so for months and months and months joe
biden did not answer
a non-pre-screen question his media team
was taking questions
from the media that they had
pre-screened basically that was the
allegation during the campaign
kamala harris did not do a single press
conference for months after being
selected
as vice presidential candidate by joe
biden not for months
meanwhile all we heard was why won't
trump talk to the press why won't he do
a press conference then when he did talk
to the press who's like why is he even
out here talking to the president okay
so here is what we are now learning
from the daily beast maxwell tony
reporting if you are a reporter with a
tough question from the white house
press secretary joe biden's staff
wouldn't mind knowing about it in
advance
according to three sources with
knowledge of the matter as well as
written communications reviewed by the
daily beast the new president's
communication staff
have already on occasion probed
reporters to see what questions they
plan on asking
new white house press secretary jen
sachin when called upon during briefings
the request prompted concerns among the
white house press corps whose members
like many reporters are sensitive to the
perception that they are coordinating
with political communication staffers
okay so first of all
the only reason gen saki is asking to
hear the question beforehand
is because she believes a lot of members
of the media will go along with that
can you imagine sarah huckabee sanders
or
kaylee mcenany emailing a member of the
new york times being like
you know what would be great is if you
could let me know what controversial
question you're gonna ask me today jim
acosta from cnn can you let me know what
you're gonna ask me
there's a reason they would never send
that email and it's because jim acosta
would immediately go on air and say they
had sent an email asking to pre-screen
questions correct
but the media are so in the pocket of
democrats that they have to anonymously
leak
this story to the daily beast shouldn't
a journalistic establishment
that cares about its own prerogative
just say openly we are not going to
engage in this
and not only we're not going to engage
in this they should say by name i am
reporter x
i have been asked by the white house to
pre-screen my questions with them i'm
not going to do that nor is it
appropriate for them to ask me to do
that
they're not doing that though instead
they're leaking they don't want to
offend you wouldn't want to offend the
biden administration jen sackey
you would not want to offend jen sackey
truth teller extraordinaire
you know how refreshing how refreshing
in the words of brian stelter so much
truth
so much transparency also if you just
submit your question in writing
beforehand so they can prep for it
or so they can ignore you that would be
just excellent that'd just be great
according to the daily beast one
reporter raised the issue during an
informal white house correspondents
association zoom call last friday
according to multiple sources leaders at
the meeting advised print reporters to
push back against requests
by the white house press team to learn
of questions in advance or simply to not
respond to the biden team's inquiries
one white house correspondent said well
it's a relief to see briefings return
particularly with a commitment to
factual information okay just a quick
note
they've already lied repeatedly gensake
went out there the very first day and
said there was no covered relief but
there was no
vaccine plan available none they entered
office and there was nothing but chaos
it was a lie it wasn't true
then she suggested that it was going to
be a dramatic ramp up to get to a
million shots a day they were already at
a million shots a day so that was a lie
as well
okay so she was already not telling
things that were but but again what
you're going to hear from the white
house press
is thank you sir may i have another
that's all this is
but yeah they're lying to us but they're
really telling the truth don't you see
they're just telling us the truth all
the time one white house correspondent
told the daily beast
the press can't really do its job in the
briefing room if the white house is
picking and choosing the questions they
want that's not really a free press at
all
it pissed off reporters for people to
flag it for the white house
correspondents association for them to
deal with said another knowledgeable
source
the white house correspondents
association zoom call was off record
daily b staffers participated in the
call those staffers had no input into
this story whatsoever
the reporter who wrote this story was
not bound by the terms of the calls
agreement
all the information in this article was
independently gathered with and without
his colleagues knowledge
so that is the this is now the daily
beast reporter trying not to out his own
colleagues
right god forbid somebody from the daily
beast who's a reporter should say you
know what it's really inappropriate that
they did this publicly
it's all got to be anonymous wouldn't
want to take off biden wouldn't want to
take off
team refreshing over there according to
the daily beast since biden took office
two weeks ago the white house press team
has visibly attempted to draw contrast
with the trump press team which had a
notoriously antagonistic relationship
with reporters
and eventually scrapped their
traditional daily briefing altogether
saki has pleased many members of the
press pool by ensuring that reporters
and attendants
aren't doing so in vain during her first
presser
saki promised to restore regular
briefings including those with top
administration health officials adding
she had a deep respect for the role of a
free and independent press and that they
shared a common goal which is sharing
accurate information with the american
people
a quick note to the american press if
you share a common goal with the person
whose literal job it is to do spin for
the white house you're not a member of
the press you're a member of the lapdog
media at that point
biden's press team did not deny that
staffers had solicited questions from
reporters
but the white house contended it had
tried to foster a better relationship
with the press corps than the previous
administration
and has tried to reach out to reporters
directly in order to avoid appearing to
dodge questions
during briefings oh that's why it's so
we can be more transparent
and honest by asking for your questions
in advance so we can spin it in advance
and then i love this even the daily
beast tries to spin this right this
practice isn't totally unheard of in
previous administrations departments or
federal agencies
for instance former president donald
trump's white house press secretary
sarah huckabee sanders was known to have
asked certain news outlets about their
questions in advance
of some major or high profile trump
oppressors or events according to two
people with direct knowledge of the
matter communication staffers during the
bush and obama years would ask reporters
for the gist of questions in advance
if they wanted to interview cabinet
secretaries that's not the same thing
that's not the same thing okay if the
idea is we are setting up an interview
with the president what kind of
questions are you going to ask the
president that's stuff that happens on
this show all the time we'll ask a guest
to come on the guests will be like what
do you want to ask me about
that's normal what is not normal is for
the press office to routinely ask
reporters what they are going to ask
them
during a normal press conference i mean
i'm sorry this is just it's ridiculous
but don't worry
according to eric schultz former deputy
press secretary in the obama white house
quote
this is textbook communications work the
briefing becomes meaningless if the
press secretary has to repeatedly punt
questions
instead of coming equipped to discuss
what journalists are reporting on
okay like let's be real about this there
are a lot of things the press secretary
should know about
and punting is the thing that like a lot
of conservatives were making fun of
gensake over the past couple of days
because she kept saying during pressers
i'm gonna circle back on that and get
back to you and people are cutting
montages we're saying
i'm going to circle back i'm going to
circle back i'm going to circle back let
me just point out that's okay to say
there's nothing wrong with jen saki
saying that she has to circle back
because she doesn't have that
information
that's fine it's normal not normal is
asking reporters what they're going to
ask her in advance of the actual
press conferences so we can stage these
things and meanwhile it's always
encouraging to hear
from the biden white house again which
again their only issue is
is what they want unity unity unity
unity that uh they would love to have
social medias
social media platforms reduce the amount
of free speech on the platform so here's
jen sackey yesterday from the white
house saying
that she wants to push social media to
reduce hate speech on their platform
she said this in response to questions
about trump being banned from social
media
this president by the support the
continuing ban of president trump on
their sites
i think that's a decision made by
twitter we've certainly spoken to and
he's spoken to
the need for social media platforms to
continue to take steps to
reduce hate speech um but we don't have
more for you on it than that
oh we we've just been pushing the social
media platforms to reduce hate speech by
hate speech we mean anything we don't
like
it's that commitment to free speech that
really is making conservatives feel good
these days
and really solidified and unified these
days with the new
administration meanwhile what kind of
free speech they like they like the
speech from the media where the media
just play cover for democrats that's
always amusing
like for example it's super fun that
msnbc
interviewed members of the lincoln
project over and over and over and over
over the past few weeks and never once
asked about allegations that the
co-founder was
was sexually soliciting young underage
people
so that's fun but msnbc did that
apparently steve schmidt is according
to media steve schmidt rick wilson
george conway all appeared on msnbc to
conduct interviews
17 times after the allegations were
first made public on january 11th
by ryan gursky according to records
collected by media clipping services
the tally was first noted by the daily
callers michael ginsberg
so it's always got to be fun to be an
msnbc person
and never ask relevant questions to
people meanwhile daniel dale remember
fact checker extraordinaire over at cnn
and his job was just to be like i'm
going to fact check everything trump
ever says
in the most didactic terms right i'm
going to get into like the nitty-gritty
details and i'm going to fact
check not only the broad statements he
makes but i'm going to like find flaws
and statements that are generally true
and then claim the airfalls so now he's
doing the opposite now as an adjunct
member of the
of the biden white house press corps he
is going to
essentially spend his days spinning on
behalf of joe biden so
on this show we played a clip of joe
biden during the campaign talking about
how if you use executive orders outside
the scope
of your executive power you are engaging
in dictatorship right he was talking
about taxes specifically but it was a
more general point
the more general point was if the
president acts outside the bounds of his
of his actual capacity then he is
engaging in dictatorship
and many of us on the right pointed out
okay you just enacted more executive
orders in the first week of your
administration
than any president in history many of
those executive orders had no actual
statutory room for you to do that
right that not every one of those
executive orders was enabled
by the members of congress in a piece of
legislation well now daniel dale has
decided his job is no longer to compile
a list of trump lies
now it's to compile a list of how
everybody's being mean to joe biden so
he did like a full five-minute thing on
cnn
about how people just keep saying mean
things about you by nintendo dale
doesn't like that very much we have to
stop saying mean things about joe biden
guys
the key word there is things biden was
saying as he did at other moments of the
campaign
that there are certain policies you
can't impose via executive order
he didn't say that executive orders
themselves are inherently dictator-like
and he didn't even say that doing a lot
of executive orders is dictator link
in fact biden explicitly campaigned on
doing a bunch of executive orders
and it's also worth noting that many of
biden's executive orders
simply reverse trump executive orders
that biden's critics never complained
about at the time
okay but i will point out that a lot of
people complain about trump's executive
orders and many of those executive
orders were successfully challenged in
court for being outside the scope of
trump's authority
so yeah i'm wonderful to see
that the fact-checkers at cnn have now
decided that their job is to just be
gensaki
and why even have gensake the media are
going to do it for you they're
coordinating with gensake and the media
are going to spend their days fact
checking
biden's critics as opposed to actually
fact-checking biden
that's very very exciting stuff so that
is where we currently stand with our
wonderful wonderful media they're doing
excellent by the way
note about the media have you noticed
that the media have turned on andrew
cuomo that only took like a year
that's fun so andrew cuomo is uh is a
garbage governor
some of us have been pointing this out
since last march that he's a garbage
governor that he is responsible
for horrific death toll inside his own
state that he
was shipping old people back into
nursing homes with covid in order to
free up hospital beds
and that resulted in mass death in the
nursing homes some of us have been
pointing out from us that there are open
reports that were pretty obviously
documented and he was under accounting
the number of
seniors who had died of covid in nursing
homes
well now the media are finally catching
up it only took seven months for them to
catch up on this thing
these are the people we should trust i
think probably so
here are jake tapper and sanjay gupta
from cnn blasting cuomo
where's chris by the way chris there to
to rebut this thing or is chris just not
gonna report on it or does he have like
a giant
uh a giant q-tip that he can make jokes
about with his brother
cnn your most trusted name in news right
here that seems like a wildly
irresponsible thing for a leader to say
during a pandemic we
we need the public to believe the
experts do you have any concerns
i'm really quite quite stunned that
that's what he said
if you start to take away some of the
the uh the credence of these experts i
think that's really really harmful
especially now
oh well i'm glad that cnn has picked up
on this by the way the new york times
has picked up on it as well
according to the new york times the
deputy commissioner for public health at
the new york state health department
resigned in late summer
soon after the director of its bureau of
comm of communicable disease control
also stepped down
so did the medical director for
epidemiology last month the state
epidemiology
epidemiologist said she too would be
leaving the drum beat of high level
departures in the middle of the pandemic
came as morale plunged in the health
department and senior health officials
expressed alarm to one another
over being sidelined and treated
disrespectfully according to five people
with direct experience inside the
department
their concern had an almost singular
focus governor
andrew cuomo this is the new york times
even as the pandemic continues to rage
and new york struggles to vaccinate a
large and anxious population cuomo has
all but declared war
on his own public health bureaucracy the
departures have underscored the extent
which pandemic policy has been set by
the governor who with his aides crafted
a vaccination program beset
by early delays now i just want to note
the timeline in this story this is the
new york times itself reporting
so when these people leave deputy
commissioner late summer soon after
the director of the bureau of
communicable disease and the medical
director for epidemiology
for epidemiology so um where was the new
york times
because last summer last night checked
was not today
today is february 2nd so where were you
guys
oh that's right you were busy massaging
his ass so yeah i think we should
definitely trust you guys
the the arbiters of truth and decency in
our media
i trust them don't you i mean they're
just so trustworthy
i mean they were praising this guy as
the governor for all americans
well done well done i can't imagine why
so many people are turning to
conservative media outlets for an
alternative source of actual information
all righty we'll be back here later
today with an additional hour of content
coming up soon the matt walsh show
airing at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to
check it out over
at dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the bench hero show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producers are
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez
the show is edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
on the matt welsh show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show
you